ON THE BRIGHT SIDE, WITH THAT
KIND OF A TONGUE, YOU WILL NEVER
BE THAT LAST BIT AUTHOR AND
COMMUNIST, STEYN, WHAT IS NOW.
MY, WAS GOING ON WITH THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN?
I KNOW IT WAS A SMALL POLE AND
IT WAS JUST ONE PULPIT ONLY 320
PEOPLE IN A BUT MY GOODNESS.
HE HAS LOST DOUBLE DIGITS IN
POINTS ON THAT VERY SAME POLE IN
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME COULD
WHAT HAS GONE ON QUESTION MARKS
TO GO YEAH, AND IT'S ONLY TWO
MONTHS AGO THAT THE HILL, WHICH
REPORTED ON THIS, WAS SAYING
THAT HE WOULD WALLOP TRUMP IN A
LANDSLIDE HEAD-TO-HEAD.
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE A BIDEN
TRUMP HAD TO HEAD.
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE --
BY THE TIME WE GET TO THE IOWA
CAUCUS IN THE NEW HAMPSHIRE
PRIMARY, OR THE VERMONT PRIORY
MARY AS, HE IS NOT GOING TO BE I
MARY AS, HE IS NOT GOING TO BE N
MARY AS, HE IS NOT GOING TO BE T
MARY AS, HE IS NOT GOING TO BE E
MARY AS, HE IS NOT GOING TO BE R
MARY AS, HE IS NOT GOING TO BE C
MARY AS, HE IS NOT GOING TO BE .
I LOVE OLD PEOPLE, I'M THE LEAST
A JUST PERSON IN THE MEDIA.
AND WHEN I LISTEN TO PEOPLE SAY
BODY MAY BE AS BEFORE WHEN HE
WAS 65, 35, 25, HE MADE HIS
GAFFES IN MIDDLE SCHOOL, THE
POINT IS WHEN HE WAS SAYING
THAT, THEY ARE GOING TO PLAY YOU
ALL BACK IN CHAINS, HE SOUGHT
VIGOR.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WITH A DECADE
AND A HALF ON HIS AGE WHO STILL
HAD MORE VIGOR.
WE TALKED TO ONE ON YOUR SHOW
THIS MORNING WHO HAD MORE ENERGY
THAN JOE BIDEN.
HE'S NOT GOING TO STICK AROUND
FOR IOWA AND NEW HAMPSHIRE
BEAUTY WILL BE GONE BEFORE THEN.
>> Brian: HE'S GOT OVER --
A WIDE SWATH, ALLIED TO S.W.A.T.
OF THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTE
AMONG DEMOCRATS FOR THE FIRST
TWO PRIMARIES DON'T HAVE A GREAT
BLACK ROAD IN HAMPSHIRE AND
IOWA.
ONE DOG IS, ONES ARE PRIMARY,
WILL YOU EVEN GET TO TALK TO YOU
AND IF HE DOESN'T GET ONE OF
THOSE?
IS THAT YOUR POINT?
>> YEAH, I DON'T.
I THINK AT SOME POINT --
HE'S IN THOSE POSITION THAT A
LOT OF EARLY FRONT RUNNERS ARE
IN.
HE'S ELECTABLE BECAUSE HE IS
LIKABLE HERE THE MINUTE YOU HAVE
MORE POLLS SHOWING HIM IN THIRD
PLACE THE PRINCIPAL RATIONALE
FOR HIS CANDIDACY EVAPORATES.
WHAT IS HIS MESSAGE?
WHAT IS HIS PLATFORM?
WHAT IS HIS SLOGAN?
WHAT IS HIS THEME?
THE ONLY THING HE HAS GOING FOR
HIM IS THAT HE'S BEEN AROUND
FOREVER, HE IS NAME RECOGNITION,
AND IS THEREFORE PRESUMED TO BE
ELECTABLE.
WHEN YOU HAVE POLLS SHOWING HIM
IN THIRD PLACE AND WORSE IF YOU
START SLIPPING INTO FOURTH PLACE
BETWEEN --
BELOW PEOPLE HE HAS NEVER HEARD
OF THREE MONTHS AGO, THE ENTIRE
RATIONALE FOR THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
DISAPPEARS.
STU AND I ASKED HER TO DO A LOT
OF THINGS IN THE PAST WHETHER
IT'S ON    ON THE FOX AND FRIENS
COUCH OR ON THIS VERY SAD SCUM
AND I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO DO
ON BETO O'ROURKE THAT HE HAS
DECIDED TO FRY A BURGER ON
CAMERA BECAUSE THE DENTIST THING
DIDN'T REALLY PAN OUT FOR HIM.
CAN YOU TRY TO EXPLAIN OR EVER
MAKE HEADS OR TAILS OF THIS?
HE DECIDES TO SELL AS HE FRIES
BURGERS?
>> WELL, BECAUSE BETO O'ROURKE
HAS BEEN DOING THIS THING WHERE
HE HAD HIS EAR HAIR TRIMMED LIVE
ON CAMERA.
THEN HE WENT TO THE DENTIST LIVE
ON CAMERA AND HE IS JUST SOME
SHALLOW NARCISSIST WITH NO
SUBSTANCE.
SO HE'S DECIDED TO SHOW US THAT
HE HAS GOT SUBSTANCE AND
FOLLOWING HIS SUCCESS AT
CHANGING A TIRE WITHOUT ACTUALLY
JACKING THE CAR OUT, HE HAS NOW
DECIDED TO FRY A BURGER.
IT'S A VERY BIZARRE SITUATION
HE'S GOT GOING THERE WITHOUT
BURGER.
THAT SEEMS TO BE SOME KIND OF
ENGLISH MUFFIN HE'S PUTTING THE
BURGER ON AND I DON'T WANT THAT
KIND OF THING --
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT TWO KINDS OF
BROCCOLI NEXT TO THE BURGER BUT
IF THIS IS WHAT THE NEW MENU IS
GOING TO BE IN THE BETA
WHITE HOUSE, THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO GET MIXED
UP WITH.
>> Brian: I THINK THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC IS REJECTING NATO'S LIGHT
APPEARED ME WILL COME ANOTHER
THING.
SENATOR CHRISTIAN CHILDREN HAS
BEEN IN THIS RACE FOREVER AND
SHE'S CHANGED HER VIEWS ON
EVERYTHING FROM IMMIGRATION TO
WHAT SHE THINKS OF THE CLINTONS
WERE WERE AN ALLY FOR YEARS AND
MENTORED HER TO THE SPOT THAT
SENATOR HILLY CLINTON WOULD
ACTUALLY GIVE UP TO BE SECRETARY
OF STATE AND NOW SHE SEEMS TO BE
CRUMBLY AND PEERED OUT AS 100
DROP OUT AND SHE IS STILL VERY
CONFIDENT IN HER MORAL
SUPERIORITY OF EVERYONE ELSE.
>> THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON
SOME BASIC MORAL PRINCIPLES.
THAT WE HAVE A MORAL COMPASS ASA
THAT WE HAVE A MORAL COMPASS ASS
A NATION, OUR MORALITY IS A
COUNTRY IS CLEARLY ON ICES EDGE.
IT'S A MORAL QUESTION.
IT I'VE BEEN CALLED TO FIGHT AS
POSSIBLY AS I CAN TO RESTORE
THAT MORAL INTEGRITY AND
DECENCY.
>> Brian: WELL IS THE MORAL
INTEGRITY AND DECENCY GOING TO
PROPEL HER DO YOU THINK?
>> NO, I THINK HER MORAL COMPASS
IS ACTUALLY SITTING AT THE
BOTTOM OF A LAKE.
SHE REPRESENTED A DISTRICT IN
UPSTATE NEW YORK HEADED BY THE
QUEBEC BORDER AND SHE HAD A VERY
MODERATE, VERY CENTRIST VIEWS
THAT SHE HAS TOSSED OVERBOARD
ALONG WITH HER TRAILING MORAL
COMPASS AND THAT THE LAST THREE
MONTHS SO SHE JUST COMES ACROSS
AS A SHALLOW OPPORTUNIST.
WITHOUT THE EXCUSE OF
JOE BIDEN'S BIDEN THAT SHE
BARELY REMEMBERS WHAT COUNTRY
SHE'S IN SO SHE IS NOT
THE SAME PERSON SHE WAS FIVE YER
THE SAME PERSON SHE WAS FIVE YES
AGO AND THAT GIVES HER
CREDIBILITY AND MAKES HER SOUND
FAKE WHEN SHE'S LECTURING ON HIS
SINS AND YOUNGEST IN OHIO ON HOW
THEY ARE SUFFERING FROM WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO JUST --
AND BODIES ALL THE WORST MOST
OPPORTUNIST MOST SHALLOW ASPECTS
OF POLITICS.
>> Brian: WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
SAY ABOUT ELIZABETH WARNER AT
BERNIE SANDERS OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY ARE